[Music]
hello Dorinda how are you thank you for
having me thank you for coming all the
way to LA just to see you we have some
Rose a can we cheers absolutely to ten
years of Real Housewives of New York
cheers Oh delicious
anticipation for this season was
building building building God then we
hear some reports of some things builds
even more yes then the trailer comes out
builds even more this might be the best
season of housewives period not just New
York of any City do you think so mm-hmm
I think so that's what the fans are kind
of put out I'll tell you I felt that and
I don't think we're letting you down at
least I'm not letting you down say it
forget it
write it regret it it's a little foolish
you don't support other with a brand of
a loser
[Music]
there are all these reports this cruise
from hell Andy Cohen told me that the
reports were misleading and maybe didn't
represent what actually happened what
would you say on that well I don't think
I mean I really don't want to comment on
it because it's sort of an uncomfortable
situation and you know I don't want to
we've talked to it wasn't a great
situation
it wasn't a positive experience okay
okay so I think that's what I can say
about that still kind of dealing with
the traumatic moment and we'll have to
wait and see what unfolds yes I think a
lot of fans expected to see it maybe a
brief moment of that in the trailer and
they are holding all that back yeah
because it's at the end of it it's at
the end of the season right that
midseason trailer yeah we'll see
something
I hope do you I see it when you see it
right so for me I bet you don't know
what you live you don't know what we're
gonna see absolutely not
so I don't know how they're gonna cheers
to you cheers to season 10 yes surviving
it you're gonna love it you're gonna
love it
I love it and I'm on it there we go
[Music]
[Applause]